okay guys and we're back we're back
let's say okay so last time last episode
we got the car to be locked tightly I
need to find it King one sec why isn't
it fullscreen let's sit here that's
right
I know why that whole screen patient is
suffering from a demonic breath that is
terrorizing him who brought the red head
to the hospital ward is to not put it
back together that good blanket plan
where is that oh good matches redhead
that's disgusting
okay we got the redhead the rat had
hospital keep bf1 okay how the carbs
wasn't there a redhead like outside the
hospital I think there is I'm gonna say
pretty quick pretty sure it was like
papers on the ground floor he was like
right outside the hospital one sec let
me just check
cuz sooner rather than sit here hospital
gowns well it's basically up I think it
was in here
woman's maybe it was over here no gonna
have broken baseball bat how was it it
was here we had a graph it darts to a
nearby door oh my god
this stores open now toreano's broken
this is the hospital what is that a
heart train stoneware trap is no escape
trolley or on the roof some probably got
to them probably squirrel rose but at
the Cordova connects air is off-limits
now how's the court over okay Oh gasp
can house / elevator key
handles broken whoa
okay this finally works okay that's so
weird
well this is really not where I want to
be okay it's gonna be another way we
ready yeah there we go there you go what
the hell okay
oh so it's like a super shortcut anyway
we got a shortcut key then all right see
what else is here okay that's from pity
what is that an old floppy disk this
thinkers in the computer oh it scared me
whatever that was said of darken he's
crazy
so the floppy disk darkness okay
don't know tell that's about but I'm
probably gonna say before just freakin
murders you cuz I already had a game
where it just got a little too nosy and
just [ __ ] got terminated hospital
room big [ __ ] in here
I was just [ __ ] locked see yeah like
no [ __ ] this one right
you're something in the door I gave that
trash kinderman no okay number four
herb number two
yeah then [ __ ] in there
number five okay bearish in this one I
bet your game called is there [ __ ] on
this room nothing in here nothing in
here that's my hands I think my hands I
knew I know that reference I don't think
so it's just Kansas right no I don't
have any see rooms these last be though
these were something that let me
continue
they're more be rooms upstairs I can't
me rattles at this song
I don't know anything about this
all right look advice the elevator well
I think she's the thing on the second
floor was like room B so Bri I gotta get
a room seat thing but I'm guessing I
gotta put the Hat thing but really who's
Eddie
anything in here more
is there more bees in there yeah then is
that but I think it there go back to the
very weather weather where I love me
that's weird there's a lot of sit here
Hannah's broken sir I got like the gas
tank call mom again
really up without the Luke my name
I can read I can read how's the [ __ ]
code of a kid all these are broken maybe
some of these doors got unlocked this
the dirt yeah
definitely something on the hospital
side so what if I don't got the hospital
he's over here doors locked
it's very curious hospital again can't
can't go there
what the hell
okay I'm a Mississippi one of these
things I don't think I did but you never
know Jesse
let's check these things again yeah
there's something in here can't just
like a head like that this one say it's
a Burton law
let's ask time sake hmm I'm ready sure
what is going on here
you have to go back up there slipping
unlock now
you go this way
hmm does you need to go to over Kay I
think I can apply to go back out and I
was fine maddening to everybody yeah
actually if you cooker just take the
elevator
now doors it's so freakin dark
there's welcome in okay so we're gonna
use the gas tank for I don't think
you're something was out of energy
switch our book happened through the
trash can can't use that anymore it's a
subway
really perplexed here it was someone
like laughing in there laughing anymore
okay I don't know how that is disgusting
there's 2:30
eleven
kid that's not anymore so he gets an
appoint he asked change yeah I'm missing
something I kind of Betty I don't know
what my only guess is that this
hmm oh just listen to this okay I don't
know what the hell that is all right um
just we've hit the cot side again
I'm already vehicle or anything back
though the rats thing was smart the
right thing would appear right there
yeah the kick do anything I guess so
check the retest thing again you never
know with these people you never know
he's gonna look out again and this look
at everything
oh my god uh it's disgusting it's just
so foul you know there's really nothing
good about it I think it'd bring these
things maybe no I guess not
oh yeah just gonna guess again no that's
disgusting the pie smells so bad
oh my god that I suppose so bad oh yeah
okay Wow
that's annoying that one is very hard to
find especially you can see backtrack to
like a scenic thing I don't know that's
gonna hard I'd say looking at
and is that
that's Sparkle man again how that sack
oh my god
I got he's mad he's mad he's I haven't
do you find that's that K had a if I
that cake
Days fall off the roof yeah
what is that
okay I'm gonna pretend I didn't fall off
the roof I'm gonna pretend it ever day
that didn't happen you know says there
when I seen that point cuz nothing
really gonna happen you know I appeared
right dad how's that weirdest thing I've
ever seen
when I start getting sissies I guess
these are the two CS
I guess the only one see Jess that buck
they put over Kate oh I got here we go
okay one one four five eleven forty-five
never got that picture I found it but if
I was the time and the word is
1:11 go 11 no wait not now no it's
actually to hell wait to go to hell
oh okay so he's saying put in at the
time 11:45 to go to hell okay we all
know what does I think I think I think
we're all old enough to know what that
is you know you know man I can't believe
it was in this stupid music I was like
over here right yeah yeah that's thing I
was like man
there we go
a larger ante I don't remember where the
heck to use that unless it take anyone
though though the rats thing this is
like in here cuz it's the only place
where thing for like locked
hmm I don't remember any remaining doors
shall I now cuz I'll save yes there's
that door in the hospital
why is he starts go okay there we go
I said I looked at bad
Oh get me clean air but hey no it's
better than trying you know
I'm not gonna trash cans and I want to
make it
not grant I've been tricked the blank
sports that one more time Jesus had
tricked into playing sports again this
has not good
I'm tired of reading tricked into
playing sports he's got this so I want
is that over there that is that Graham
graveyard
Robert and there
they programmer
I'm right here yeah you tell us a lot of
sports in it there's that okay hey thank
you thank you so much sir okay that was
our sewer your super beer
I remember a sewer being right here
so working where was there a sewer how
are you
yeah yeah we are flying through this
hey that came how does that finally all
those keys over there
place is huge down right here let's make
sure I can't go anywhere I'm gonna do a
lock need one ten thousand keys okay I
start let me take it down a lot of crap
here gonna kidding into cake you know I
need is safe point as I need
five one five one one okay then take
picture this okay house north don't
really understand this but it's actually
north voices at North one one five five
a lot so I was a find out what north is
that's make this correct direction
- five five one more time five one five
one one okay so this is too early right
here
which way is north nobody knows
hey there's locked
you gotta have that next chamber so many
keys over there
what is a north south west eats that's
the way the demon face
I'm gonna discuss it over here okay I
guess gotta push all these four button
so I got one of four
let's open that up ten Lampard's
cab so I find out all the buttons slowly
find it all the buns to murtis it locked
anything is it disgusting
well you know I guess I'll end this
episode here before we can tell you a
lot more thanks for watching
[Music]